hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to one shot now we left
Nico in the darkness and Nico was saying
something new that I'm not entirely sure
I liked Oh
markiplier let me know when you're back
I'm back I don't know why this keeps
happening I'm sorry I can't play it all
in one setting that's so sad oh I hope
the squares don't spread too fast B the
way I showed him the book and I rescued
his sister but these people have been
living alone for a while
and their back room is full of dust and
cobwebs so I just got to keep going
forward and hopefully I won't need to
leave Nico too much longer now
find out what's in the rest of this
caverns they got going on here whoa hey
I saw you going to the courtyard so I
thought I'd tag along same all right
okay then just cuz I'm in your backyard
doesn't mean that I plan to do anything
dastardly like steal your clothes or
nothing like that just cuz I'm not from
this world
oh wow so there's a never-ending series
of caverns oh hi there mysterious
children that follow me looks like it
used to lead somewhere yeah the sacred
grounds it's been a while since we went
there we don't have any way of getting
there now
there isn't a boat none of us can swim
and what's the sacred grounds it's where
our people are buried sometimes we go
there to visit mom well a grave anyway
oh wait how do you get there I thought
you said there isn't a boat
our friends helps us he has some sort of
machine that allows him to fly sometimes
he takes us along aren't you Birds don't
you have wings and feathers but like I
was about to say we haven't seen him
around for a while I wonder when he'll
come back I wish we could go see mom
again oh come on alula let's get back to
the courtyard my god I didn't shout the
word Lula it's a breakthrough come on
sis okay man that's so sad though maybe
death is like a common concept in this
world because the whole world's dying
it's a ball that's mine don't touch it
it doesn't bounce around as much as it
used to though
Bing bong I fishy fish fish can I have
some I'm quite ravenous as a fellow fish
eater being a cat an old man you leaving
now
good luck Nico we believe in you are you
leaving it was nice to meet you
really thanks for everything oh god man
that's so sad
well who's the guy that helped you fly
that's so sad oh well I guess I got a
press forward maybe I can take the Sun
back now cuz I already made my way down
here so I guess I don't really need to
do anything else get a girlfriend
gotta take that to the tower and fix
this world but then again like it's just
so sad to think about that maybe this
world can't be fixed so why am I here oh
[Music]
she's gone Oh something on the ground
here looks like a kernel of corn she
must have left it behind this seed the
light's gone out good marker Blair do
you know what happened
no you really i know i i'm supposedly
all-knowing but in this one instance i
don't have an idea what am I gonna do
oh there goes you sad to touch it it lit
up again
phoof yeah it only lights when you touch
an eco oh my god
but if that means that Nico has to stay
at the tower and the reason the light
went out last time was because the last
person died
I mean that's a morbid thought and I
have no evidence to that idea but
following logic they wouldn't actually
do that would they
that'd be heartbreaking but then again
there's a lot of themes of death in this
game oh I know what I need to do the
feather and the bottle of die I can use
it as a pen and then a seed left behind
by maze ooh mazes corn that means corn I
think in Spanish and also in other
countries it's called maze as well but
so now I can take this bat in this
bottle of ink and then I can use it or I
can use it as a pen I can take it over
to the robot and hopefully he's not
gonna smack me it was dying scroll and
then I'll be able to progress further at
least they gave me a lucky glowing
feather and the sacred feather that
they've given me trusted with me one
that they've held onto from their dead
father and I'm gonna use it as a pen
first thing I did literally the first
thing I did was dip it in ink so good
job for me I'm an [ __ ]
markiplier I'm too tired to go on right
now please let me nap for a bit
somewhere
[Music]
I don't know where didn't let you nap
there's bad back in the kids place do
you want a nap there dad three I mean
another whose bed was despair I guess
we'll go there then it's a bad dammit
not these beds alright then gotta find
somewhere to sleep do I remember seeing
any of those special light bulb beds
anywhere because I do not unfortunately
ooh hello oh well that's gonna be an en
a would let you by the clovers I don't
remember this even being here before I'm
a little tired from walking is it
alright if I take a nap
yes goodbye I guess Oh another dream run
oh that's so sad
markiplier I had another dream did you
see this one too yeah I was in a big
field like the one in my last dream and
I saw my village but then I woke up yeah
I don't think this world there's
anything like that I mean big wheat
fields the only big plants I've seen
here a bunch of weird trees and there's
balls of moss floating in the water
wait it's moss even if the plant say
have you seen a wheat field before
markiplier yes I have oh they're really
pretty aren't they the one around my
village goes around for miles the plants
are really tall sometimes I can't even
see through them when it's windy out the
wind can make waves on it it's like an
ocean of food I'll wait but there's food
and regular oceans too like fish crabs
I've never actually been to a real ocean
until now actually I've been to the
ocean oh yes it's really cool I've only
seen the ocean on TV before never
thought I'd get to ride a boat through
one the water back home doesn't have the
glowy stuff like how it is here even I
guess it's because this world is already
so dark you know I used to be scared of
the dark mark
it's a little hard to imagine that now
after spending so much time here but not
long ago I couldn't even go to sleep
without a lamp oh it's good you got over
that I guess otherwise I wouldn't last
long here then again I've been carrying
around the Sun so it's not too bad
also I don't feel scared at all with you
guiding me maybe you should I'm not the
best guide so thanks for that
anyway maybe we should have our
markiplier alright okay whatever you say
now we got to get over to this guy gosh
sign up a Fang nope that's that's wrong
there we go hello I found a pen sort of
good please write your name here thank
you I think
I don't know where I'm going now but
thank you woah why am i walking on the
ramparts Wow what in the world I thought
it was gonna chase me for a second there
I guess I can't go back though that's
bad no no no don't do that
that's no good that's no bueno oh whoa
I've made it to the city already that's
so weird because that whole other place
was just me talking to these people
[Music]
oh that's that's thumping that's got a
good thump to it that's real parallax II
- ah ah the Sun hello Messiah
welcome to the refuge do you understand
what you must do here I'm supposed to go
inside the tower right all right see the
tower so I guess we must be close
where's the entrance on the surface the
surface look down small one oh we're
pretty high up I guess I gotta go down a
lot of stairs or find an elevator
correct
however the tower is a sacred place
finding the entrance may be easy but
that alone will not be enough what do
you mean
once you reach the service I recommend
visiting the library for leads all right
thank you
off you go then I wish you luck mmm okay
I'm afraid this area's off-limits for
you gonna smash your head in with my
giant robot fists if you go any further
only the bearer of the sacred kernel is
permitted access to the garden I've got
a I've got a seed is it sacred what
about the seed Oh like a kernel of corn
I have this it was left behind by a
plant lady in the Glen that is indeed
the kernel then it is your duty to
regrow her do you understand what you
must do no not at all no I don't know
take the seed to the garden plant it in
the pot in the center you may now pass
through here to access the garden
alrighty then thank you where's this pot
you were talking about mmm okay oh why
would she regrow here
[Music]
there's no dirt in the spot will the
seed really grow oh I see yeah I got
tube water but no dirt ah
did anybody seen a pile of dirt around
here dirt uh yeah hi
looks like dirt yeah pile it's in a pile
answers to the name dirt pile Oh dirt
maybe you know by its maiden name
anybody just let me know if everybody
sees a pile of dirt why is there no
floor here alright then I have no
commentary about that's look for balls
dirt anybody got some dirt anybody you
he she got dirt we anybody okay whoa
come on come on work already huh what
was that huh someone angry about
something might be markiplier have you
ever thought of that oh hello
come on come on I'm too busy for this
excuse me
whoa you're you Jesus I didn't think I
was gonna run in it this is embarrassing
is there anything I can help you with
yes please I'd like to know how to get
to the surface yeah I was afraid you
were gonna say that
right now this elevator is the only way
to access the surface but yeah just take
a look at it it's broken it's an
elevator well you're not wrong Messiah
but go look at the button panel huh
there aren't any buttons yep that's the
problem
it's usually a big button higher that
says ground on it you know cuz it takes
you to the ground area but uh it's been
ripped out or something I don't know
tried looking everywhere for it but to
no avail
maybe it exploded do you think we'll
have to make a new one how we'll figure
it out
I got a god on my side that I'm talking
to in my brain head hey you ever heard
about me talking to God and I'm I'm the
Messiah of the Sun in my hands
sharing concerns about that do you think
you'd be able to make that button no
pressure I'll just stick with my
original plan for now to kick that door
in the sky me this guy's literally me ha
Bisky Schwab I am my foot hurts okay all
right you keep trying buddy have fun
with that oh [ __ ]
the squares again just stupid squares
okay all right then
well where the hell are we supposed to
go then we gotta find us some gosh darn
dirt and then we gotta make a button
somehow hey you guys I'm looking for
some dirt good old-fashioned dirt you
mind if I take this okay nevermind then
taking it anyway I don't need permission
I talked to a God in my head ah hi there
hello how come there aren't any people
here normally cafes have tons of people
yeah it's a really slow day do you think
it's because the ground access elevator
is broken so I've been told the city's
infrastructure has been suffering a lot
lately
sky walks and stares breaking off left
and right now the only reliable way a
transporter those elevators till now
anyway so who lives up here why do
people live up here
coffee machine it's nearly full milk and
sugar I like both but not in cafe you
know this hall guy came in here earlier
the same thing he asked me if I've seen
a button this is ground on it he looked
pretty stressed so I wanted to cheer him
up I told him the only ground I have
seen today is coffee grounds yeah he
didn't get it and he didn't like me and
he didn't give me his number and he
didn't date me I'm lonely all right bye
it says Kafka
so maybe there's a way to have someone
rip the ground off of it and turn it
into a button I'm using kid logic here
but sometimes gate logic works sometimes
kid logic is the best kind of logic and
you need that you need it if you can
craft a button out of it maybe it's
gonna take you where you need to go I'm
pretty sure anyway I don't know
understand but I'm pretty sure your
litter I'm gonna you just stand there
kicking you you're real good kicker
you're the greatest kicker I've oh I'll
bed well you're not tired yet I bet I
gotta go solve this puzzle before you be
going off to sleep spill but at least I
know where the bed is I'm gonna say I
know that hello
does anybody live here does everyone
just trapped in their buildings because
the sky walks are breaking apart from
the darkness this sounds like a
possibility hello
don't mind me breaking and entering I'm
the Messiah talking to a guy to my head
he's telling me to do this don't know
why it's that way in there ooh hello an
abstract painting landscape hello are
you onion are i model aid XM home
security bot sea ATM serial number 3 9 2
3 2 b 8 3 9 w4 we'll have to report you
oh sorry I kind of just walked in
because the door was unlocked also I am
the Messiah
there's my Messiah powers be scared yet
do you want me to leave scanning for
suspicious activity suspicious
activities detected zero well I guess as
long as they don't do anything bad
alrighty then like access this computer
it's off its
I am still monitoring you alert level
had been set to low don't worry I
promise I'll be a good guest just
snooping through all their things
markiplier someone lives here we can't
just sleep in their bed
well can we sit in their chair then yeah
I think so okay so their computers off
how do you turn it on our guess is just
not gonna do that
I guess move on hello hello hello
Messiah here all the family photos hi
mind me breaking and entering hmm is
that a penguin it's a big penguin flash
yellow penguin [ __ ] you
Jesus hello Jesus that's not okay
whatever they're not okay right where's
your bank window [ __ ] nothing
alrighty then goodbye maybe I need to
give her an item or something but I
don't know hello hi would you like to
play a game oh sure what game would you
like to play
do you know rock paper scissors desire
difficulty level huh Ziya duration of
turns please set your timer never mind
hi my parents are like literally never
home but I don't mind I'm used to it
besides I've got model CWT 2nd gen unit
before II here to keep me company now
she's still like stalks a little weird
sometimes that's okay she's learning if
I work real hard she might even be tamed
someday what does that mean what does
that mean you're not giving us any
answers here I keep hearing that word
what tame
nobody's told me what it means yet this
is a robot thing I can't really explain
it either ah thank you thank you for
that it's off can you turn on your
computer
large file bucks robot instruction
manual various other [ __ ] things on
the walls that I don't care about and
can't be bothered to read hello hello
just break it oh god it's a goat herder
dong hello
I just moved here from the Glen things
are so different in the city you been to
the Glen right yeah everything's so
green back there I really miss is my
neighbor gave me some plans to cheer me
up but my goddamn goat keeps eatin on
the plants in her quest to uh stay alive
like what the hell okay then
hi Betsy okay the remains of a potted
plant books on what petal is called city
life what to expect good to know that
everybody here reads instruction manuals
Billy Dee Dee Liddy another Roomba I'm
not sure what this is little car you
should ride it as your god I demand that
you ride that Roomba what come on I know
what I'm talking about
hey hey oh ah yeah yeah that's a good
stuff it's off its off ah this is the
life
oh gosh oh there's you guys leaving the
bed oh well coward as your guide and
strict you oh well that was fun okay
then oh I got an achievement we ride at
dawn oh that's a nice okay so someone
who has dirt Hey
do you have a plan for ahead that's a
little I gotta lie it's a little weird
little weird lil weird hello that you
have a lot of plants I do I grew them
all by cell you see feel free to ask me
about them not oh you're a gardener
right
I am literally a plant do you happen to
have any dirt for growing plants I mean
do do you need some yes I'm supposed to
plant a seed left behind by a plant lady
but the pond the garden doesn't have any
soil I see you're the Messiah I know
you're talking about yeah she's evil
here take this whole bag Thanks okay
alright then thank you that was easy
small garden trowel the handle part is
shaped like an owl it's an owl trial I
get it I get it too probably the only
plant hardy enough to survive naturally
outside the gland personally I think
they're really boring to look at one of
my customers really loves him though I
think all the black clovers I'm growing
here for him actually come to think of
it I haven't seen him in a while I
wonder when he's coming to pick these up
I'm afraid he might be on the Barrens
and probably did that's one for tree
unlike the ones we saw in the gland I
always wondered where the leaves they're
not dead are they Oh
although these trees are composed of all
wouldíve his you they're closer to grass
Anatomy wadis so the branches are
actually leaves sure what's interesting
about these plants is the amount of hosh
furs out they can generate phosphor
that's the glowy stuff right yep Piper
can saw our light energy and slowly a
minute over time most of the phosphor
from this world still contains energy
from above our one went out this guy's
turning into Worf says here without
those Sun or recharge them though well
let's talk about something else huh
we're all gonna die
empty flowerpot okay so I think that's
probably everything that I need thus far
be sure not who's Hutto's those are the
plans have only recently sprouted it's
not easy for a plan to make it out there
these days except for my noggin I'm
literally a plan we got those growing
lamps but they're a poor substitute for
the Sun yeah the light bulb and all that
maybe hmm
now that wouldn't be the case then the
plan lady wouldn't wanted it but maybe
maybe Niko's this Sun eyes and all that
I don't know cuz this is just a bulb but
without Niko the light goes out
so maybe the Sun is Niko after all hello
hi decorative this fridge has magnets on
it
my favorite maybe they'll come in handy
hope nobody will mind us taking this Hey
as your God I say that it's probably
okay maybe a little bit I have no idea I
have no idea of what morality even is
piled large books it look like phone
books good didn't know but hey some of
the pages are dog-eared okay pile large
books do you have a TV Fred hey there
you the Messiah
mm-hmm I like your scarf thank you
mama made it for me tell her I like your
needlework I will when I see her again
if I Syrian
that's really sad looks like I can
unlock this door but why would i ah it
leads back so I don't have to go all the
way back to go over here but now I have
I have dirt so I can put that in the
potted plant in the center of the garden
then I should be able to water it with
my vial of water and then that should be
enough right then I can get her to cut
open this coffee can and turn it into a
gosh-darn button maybe I don't know if
that's even a possibility at this point
but I'm willing to try anything because
game logic dictates that's probably to
work okay there's no dirt
oh maybe Nico you should put your turn
in there don't combine it put it in
there hope this helps you grow little
seed the seeds in the soil but it looks
a bit dry a little parched if you ask me
good thinking markiplier water shoot out
this seed grow I'm a very smart guy
there it's nice and moist now but what
if it dries out it's only so much water
from this little tube I hold on to the
tube for now just in case what do I need
to get more water we've given it dirt
and water but will that be enough no
fertilizer pick up some poop no I guess
that's not all we need this is indeed a
puzzling puzzle oh I don't think I've
gone this way bill oh I gotcha I gotcha
I gotcha this must be the way that I
need to go I get it oh yeah
again why does everybody ever sing down
the head good afternoon
well if the time of day doesn't really
mean anything now with the Sun gone the
night never seems to end it then how can
you tell time I mean have you not looked
at my freaking face you freaking [ __ ]
I am literally a clock good evening your
time is precious please do cherish it
okay what'd you do in there game have a
piece of metal set into a wall I think
it might be a door or a vault small
screen in the middle game ye getting so
ominous on me huh oh yeah why are you
getting so ominous yeah you gonna tell
me that one riddle me that wow I've
actually never been to a big city before
all these lights all these people I
guess most of the world's population
lives here yep yeah they do they do Niko
they do indeed and there it's very
different from my village the village is
very small and surrounded by huge fields
you saw a bit of that in one of my
dreams from while ago it's all building
Zin our village are only two storeys
tall
[Music]
and ego what about you markiplier what
do you live I live in a city like this
Wow can't imagine living in a city must
be exciting and kind of scary the view
is nice though
yeah oh man
that seemed like a big long final place
wait did I just go in a big circle wait
was that just a big circle okay I don't
care I get it that's just a big walkway
for Nikko to look out and see the scope
of the amount of people here oh hi yes
you want to give me a puzzle you're
going to need this soon take this film
and expose it to the void the answer
will be revealed when you bring it back
again the computer printed out a strange
transparent sheet okay so what is the
void transparent sheet filled with
numbers all right is the void up there
are you talking about the red sparkly
things the squares those dang squares
Zoe you're talking about cuz it can't be
this can't be the void the void must be
the squares because everyone said that
the void sends you somewhere and I don't
know where now it's got to be the
squares so I gotta expose it to one of
those if I'm gonna be able to do
anything let's go over here first just
to make sure there's nothing over here
Stabler it's bolted almost deal they're
both bolted so people won't steal them
feel free to use them tape the Spencer
bolted to the table alrighty then some
kind of computer terminal not the one
that hacks my brain I am the power room
mechanic do you have an issue to report
yeah actually the surface access elver
it appears to be broken it's a button
missing and can you go take a look
leaving this room is not in my
programming oh never mind
okay thank you you're so not helpful
okay so I need to I bet there's
something in here that I can
manipulate apparently not this cuz I
just looked at it with this what could I
maybe this weird expose it to the void
you say I didn't even look at this thing
I don't know what the void is what's the
void I don't know what that is
[Music]
alright okay I'm gonna go over there and
expose it to some void
maybe the void the void is wait hang on
the void might be and there's a reason
it fills up on the screen the void might
be me closing out the game right here
you cannot perform oh I had whoo you see
that no no nothing
thought I had something there thought I
was onto something
thought I was onto something yes I was
not so I gotta figure this out so I need
something more for the plant I need to
expose this to the void
right I can reveal this tube with more
water here ah okay so I got some more
water for that that might be good that
might be what I need maybe I can fill
the metal can with it it's a sink okay
never mind then okay but I got more
water do I just need to make trips back
and forth until I fill it up the only
things that I can do right now
apparently I don't even know where the
void as where's the boy oh you're still
here would you um like anything I can
cook something for you if you want it's
all right thank you
no I'm very hungry can you actually
maybe do that do you know anything about
this all right well don't be afraid the
guy's gonna get hungry I'll be happy to
make you something okay all right well
I'm asking now how about it climate is
this the void this is not the void all
right then I have no idea where the void
is I'm a little tired from walking is it
all right if I take a nap yeah okay
freakin there goes again okay but I'm
thinking that maybe that's the void uh
and if that's not the void then I just
wasted my chance to go to bed oh hello
oh is that mama nom nom
oh but it's just dream ha Marga boy I
have another dream
mama was there did you see her yes she
made me pancakes I think it was my
birthday cuz people always get their
favorite foods on their birthday a whole
lot of it do you have a birthday too
yeah I do I was born wait
no I'm a god then what's your favorite
food the pancakes wait do you like
pancakes hell yeah I like pancakes Nico
my last birthday I had ten of them I was
so full I didn't eat anything else that
day my mama makes the best pancakes and
some of the neighbors make really good
noodles and all one of our neighbors
make a lot of bread do you have any
neighbors yeah oh do they share their
food with you not got it out it's not
very nice of them our neighbors and my
momma take turn making for the food for
the whole village each day
everyone also takes turns doing chores
and watching the little kids I don't
need to be watched anymore though I'm
old enough to help out I miss everyone
I've been gone for a while now haven't I
I wonder if they're worried about me
speaking of helping out we should
probably go now
okay maybe did that void it up
no it did not
it didn't do Dinkley do CLE so that was
not the answer I know I know I know
you've lost a lot of time whoopee
whoopee do I guess I've got nothing to
help you with but at least I can go this
way and hopefully do something I don't
know why I can do something can I get
another clue still clueless yeah pretty
much
figures on another tip yeah I lay it on
me cuz avoid beyond the four walls that
bind our world to yours
the edges of your viewport where
everything is obscured I'm sure you know
what I'm talking about
Oh so but I thought I did that so if I
drop this down drop it up or what if I
move it fine Wow then the [ __ ] void I
flip dick and dragged it off-screen six
three oh one four I don't know what to
do with those numbers but I got it
ah-huh screen is off alright then six
three oh one four whatever it was so
what does that do for me what is that
how does that fix my situation hmm small
screen in the middle but I don't think I
can do anything for that
six three oh one four exposed to the
void I thought it is maybe minimizing
and maximizing it would have died but a
void is more than I thought it was but
what am I gonna do with these numbers I
don't exactly have a oh there was a
terminal up in the other area there was
a terminal it didn't let me do anything
before but maybe it'll let me do
something now some kind of terminal now
poopy poopy poopy poopy poopy poopy
poopy I am a little lost oh you see I
have exactly 14 seconds to start running
what the hell not sure if I want to play
anymore
oh session abort are you feeling unwell
no stop that okay what game would you
like play I'll pass okay all right then
don't you like to play run away from the
killer robot at least I have fun with it
okay alright then okay so I've been
walking around in circles for a little
bit here I still haven't quite figured
it out but I'm on the right track I've
got magnets I've got a coffee ground can
so there's got to be something I can do
to combine these two things maybe tear
one off the other and then the magnets
should be able to magnetize to the thing
and then maybe that'll all be done but
amount of time for this episode here so
hopefully I'll be able to get to the
next one come on take it I gotta close
the world on you so thank you everybody
so much for watching let me know I'm
doing down the comments below and I know
I'm close to the answer I just I'll get
there in the next one and then make some
more progress down the way so thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
[Music]